yeah well you know we're working on that
and you know we had a plan to totally uh
it's such a ridiculous situation isn't
it but we had a plan and we would have
instituted that plan and it was already
but uh we will get it but if we win
that's going to be taken care of that
will be one of the easy things we do um
hey how will you fix this thing oh well
it's terrible what's going on we had a
plan if we win we're going to do it very
quickly and it's just horrible what's
going on with that but we have a plan
you know that don't you this is what you
say when you quite literally have no
idea what the subject matter is that
you're being asked about